juicy smellye is convicted for lying
about juices melies paying juices
melia's friends to fake a hate crime
against
juicy sommelier
and we walk down memory lane remembering
our elite's response to the smellier
race hoax i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
thousands of my listeners have already
secured their internet join them at
expressvpn.com
speaking of which using the internet
without expressvpn it's a very dumb idea
it's basically like leaving your
computer just on a coffee table shop at
the airport unlocked for anyone to look
at perhaps it will be there when you get
back or perhaps it will not why would
you leave all your information out there
for anybody else to grab use expressvpn
instead expressvpn creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet so your online activity
can't be seen by anyone i use expressvpn
on all my devices it works on everything
phones laptops even routers so everyone
who shares your wifi can still be
protected even if they don't have
expressvpn the best part is that using
expressvpn is as easy as just closing
your laptop and putting in your backpack
and walking away you fire up the app you
click one button and you are now
protected
expressvpn is the world's number one
rated vpn by mashable the verge and
countless others so if you're like me
and you believe your online activity is
your business secure yourself by
visiting expressvpn.com
slash ben today again use my exclusive
link e-x-p-r-e-s-s
you can get an extra three months for
free that's expressvpn.com
slash ben use it today protect your data
from pryingisexpressvpn.com
ben alrighty so
jesus
may end up in jail when i say may that's
because he has not been sentenced yet
he faces up to 20 years in prison
because he was convicted on five of the
six counts brought against him according
to the new york times a jury in chicago
found the actor jucis mourier guilty on
thursday of falsely reporting to the
police he had been the victim of a
racist and homophobic assault in 2019 an
attack investigators concluded was a
hoax directed by the actor himself with
its finding after more than nine hours
of deliberation the 12-person jury
indicated it had chosen to believe the
accounts of two brothers who testified
that mr smith had asked them to mildly
injure him as part of a publicity stunt
i love that i love that the new york
times has to phrase it this way the jury
chose to believe that you
there was no evidence for any other
account
like justice moliere
literally had no plausible account of
anything that happened
other than what actually was the truth
it wasn't just that the defense had no
defense it was that the defense's
attempts at a defense were so laughably
bad that there was no possible way for a
rational human being to come to any
other conclusion than that juicy smelly
had staged an attack on juicy smellier
and frankly
i'm glad to live in a kind of i think
jesse smelly should be very glad to live
in a country where his attacker is going
to prison
i mean it's sad that they're going to be
sharing a cell but it's it's kind of
the best thing that ever happened in the
history of mankind according to the new
york times
mr smilet wearing a dark gray suit and a
blue shirt sat upright in his chair
hands clasped staring at directly at the
jury just after the verdict was read
daniel webb the special prosecutor who
handled the case said afterwards only
made matters worse by continuing to
stand by his account at trial
though that of course is
is very very very true okay so in a
second we're going to go through the
entire history of the
saga because it is so
illuminating about what america's media
life is right now how the elites view
the rest of the country the massive
disconnect between this little bubble of
people who will believe any narrative
that casts america in an evil racist
light an actual reality where people
like jesus
in american society celebrities who are
double minorities because he's gay and
black they're not treated as outcasts in
american society far from it okay the
fact is that juicy smoothie was believed
and cherished and treated as a victim
because there are elites in our society
who believe that everyone like jucy
sommelier's victim and therefore should
receive special benefit should receive
special treatment
okay and and the reality again is is
very different when it comes to crime
stories from what the media would have
you believe
wilfred riley who's a college professor
who writes for commentary magazine
sometimes really really great with his
black commentator on on race and crime
he says you know the media tried to say
that the jucy incident as originally
narrated narrated by by justice mode was
indicative of broader trends in american
public life he tweets out this morning
but there are real justice movies uh
brah violence interracial crime
involving blacks and whites is about
three percent of all serious crime and
of that three percent about 80 is black
on white
yep but that's not the narrative that
the media are attempting to propagate
and so juicy smoothie became a national
news story with everyone just we have to
believe them even though it was the
least plausible story ever okay it was
it was a super non-plausible story it
was as plausible as the story that
michael jackson had naturally sired
children right there are stories that
just aren't plausible and you can look
at them you can see right from the
outset that they're not plausible and
maybe you hold back maybe you say okay
i'm not going to jump on this one i'm
just going to wait and see what evidence
emerges but our entire media
infrastructure our entire political
infrastructure went into overdrive to
try and use the smoothie
incident as the tip of the evil american
iceberg
and even now the media are trying to buy
this back it's hysterical even now the
media are trying to say well
conservatives this doesn't mean that
that your case is helped great piece
today from jahan jones over at msnbc
titled what conservatives should realize
before they relish the juicy smelly
verdict oh tell me tell me sir
i wait with baited breath
the actor josie smithier has been found
guilty of lying to police in 2019 when
he claims he was the victim of a racist
homophobic attack in chicago bringing to
a close one of the more bizarre bizarre
celebrity cases in recent memory says
this columnist for msnbc
sommelier told police in 2019 he had
been assaulted by two masked white men
who shouted pro-trump slogans poured a
bleach-like substance on him tied a rope
around his neck but two brothers
abimbola and ola bingo usandero
testified that smollette asked them to
stage the attack
abimbola osandero who said he was
friends with milad at the time accused
the actor of orchestrating the incident
to draw media attention to actual hate
mail he received in 2019. by the way i
have doubts about the actual hate mail
in 2019 even given the fact that
made it a massive issue why aren't
people paying attention to this hate
mail that i received that basically
looks like i signed it
a la bin josender told prosecutors malet
had this crazy idea of getting attacked
by two trump supporters so he could post
it on social media some letter held
throughout the trial the incident was
not a hoax nonetheless the strange
seemingly ever-changing details in the
case have provided nearly three years
worth of material for comedians and
online commentators some of it has been
quite funny in fact as this columnist
for msnbc even more comical in my view
was the predictable conservative outrage
over smallett's allegations
conservatives took to social media in
2019 to express outrage over the dropped
charges how dare someone makes a heinous
claim about followers of their dear
leader they screeched violent masked
white guys who shot trump slogans and
used chemical agents to attack victims
many on the right shamed those of us who
knew such a claim was totally plausible
and then the january 6th insurrection
happened yes this is their defense to
everything is january 6. or
alternatively you are so unbelievably
full of crap
okay that is the alternative the
alternative is you guys are unbelievably
full of crap there's no defense to the
fact that you fell for this because it
was ridiculous from the outset
oliver darcy over it at brian stelter's
newsletter on cnn is also trying to play
the game where conservatives are wrong
for chortling over the outcome of this
this verdict
he says that it's really bad because
this is this means that conservatives
are going to use this in order to attack
media credibility guys you don't need
any help you've destroyed your own
credibility you are thelma and louise
over that cliff in that caddy
flying okay you don't need our help for
gravity to apply gravity just applies to
you you were stupid enough to buy all of
this you were brian stelton went on air
and portrayed this as fact and now you
guys are upset because conservatives are
pointing out that you have no
credibility and you guys are a mockery
okay so it's time to go back in time
just a little bit too to the original
jesus
story
so you'll remember that juicy smellier
was an actor on a show called empire
empire of course is a show that is
largely watched by black americans
not a lot of racist whites watching
empire that's just not a thing
so judy smilier was staying in chicago
and he told cnn okay this is this is the
the way cnn reported this story january
16th 2020.
empire actor justice melies was attacked
in the early morning hours on tuesday in
what chicago police are calling a
possible hate crime
smollette was attacked by two people who
were yelling out racial and homophobic
slurs and poured an unknown chemical
substance on the victim police said one
of smilet's alleged attackers also put a
rope around his neck according to police
both fled the scene
took himself to northwestern hospital
and is in good condition authorities
said
as of tuesday evening a chicago police
spokesperson told cnn that investigators
canvassed the neighborhood
where the reported attack occurred and
have found no still images or video from
security cameras of the incident the
only image of smolette police obtained
from security cameras was inside a
subway sandwich shop near the location
of the reported crime the actor was seen
standing alone
chicago police detectives continue to
investigate the serious allegations
according to the pd spokesperson anthony
gliemi okay this is the original report
gaming said detective teams would
broaden their search work around the
clock to look for video on traffic
cameras buses and neighboring streets
okay so the way that that juice juicy
smellier narrated this crime
it was 2 a.m
in chicago in the middle of a polar
vortex it was like
zero degrees outside
and juicy was hungry for a subway
sandwich so first of all this is an
implausible story
i don't know a single human being exists
on planet earth who has ever gotten up
in the middle of the night at 2 am in a
polar vortex to go to subway
that is really not credible
first of all
no slur on subway but they had a kosher
subway in l.a for a little while um it's
not
good it's certainly not the kind of food
that drives you out of 2am to polar
vortex
but
don't the sandwich will come back into
the story momentarily so jesus goes down
to subway
he's happily munching on his sandwich as
he walks the streets of chicago and
we're talking about like kind of the
tony area of chicago okay this is like
the bluest area of the blue areas of
chicago he is he's walking the streets 2
a.m when suddenly out of nowhere he's
attacked by two red hatted presumably
mega added white men white men
and they shouted him that he is a that
he is a f word n word
f word for gay person n word for black
person
from empire so apparently we have found
the only true trump supporters on planet
earth is the original story that was
deemed as you'll see seems unbelievably
credible by everyone
the these are the only two trump
supporters who have ever seen empire or
heard of empire as it turns out and
there are huge empire fans except they
really hate that there's a black gay guy
in a show that's entirely about black
people
so they start yelling slurs as you see
and then one of them takes a clothesline
and wraps it around juicy's neck and he
begins to fight them he begins to fight
them and then another one of them takes
a bottle of a bleach-like substance and
starts pouring it all over as you see
nobody knows why
doesn't even make any internal sense
this story and finally jesus fights his
way free
and in his
heroically never loses the sandwich
heroically when he emerges there's tape
now yeah we fancy when he emerges from
underneath the area where he is being
attacked by these maggots headed
by by by stephen miller and steve bannon
what after this happens you see emerges
with his subway sandwich clutched into
it so first of all just gotta say subway
is missing an unbelievable branding
opportunity because if you are subway
this guy loves subway sandwiches so much
that he is willing to not only fake a
racial attack
but hold on to the sandwich during the
racial attack undermining his entire
case and eventually landing himself in
prison because he loves subway that much
forget jared i mean you probably should
forget jared it turns out that that that
got awkward but juicy as a substitution
for jared
pretty solid stuff okay fine so then
juicy goes home
and he calls the cops and the cops show
up and when they arrive
you see is still wearing the clothesline
around his neck which is an odd fashion
choice
and the police are like can we have your
phone served so we can see your location
and he's like no
well that's suspicious
he's like no you can't see my phone
of course because he'd been texting the
two guys that he that he actually you
know
hired and and by the way jucy is such an
idiot that when jucy hired people to
commit a crime against him he did it by
check
to commit a federal crime he
signed a to commit a federal hate crime
he signed a check to make that happen
for himself
which is just the best it's just this
okay so in a second we're going to get
to justice melies treatment by the media
we're going to get to you see smoothie
what he told everybody
at the time
because it is spectacular and wonderful
and just great we'll get to that in just
one moment first
let's talk about the pillow that you use
each and every night so the pillow that
i use is my pillow and my pillow
wants to give back to our listeners you
get great discounts on all my pillow
products if you go to mypillow.com right
now and click on the radio listener
specials get deep discounts on my
pillows mattress toppers towels and so
much more for example my pillow is
offering a buy one get one free offer on
giza sheets these are top quality sheets
you will love them all my pillow
products come with a 60 day money back
guarantee and a 10 year warranty go to
mypillow.com click on the radio listener
specials for the buy one get one free
offer on the giza sheets use promo code
dailywire at checkout or call
800-651-1148
you'll also get deep discounts on all my
pillow products including pillow
slippers the my pillow mattress stopper
and my pillow towel sets that's
mypillow.com
enter daily wire or call 1-800-651-1148
tell them the daily wire sent you that
is 1-800-651-1148
my pillow pillows there's a reason
they're so popular because they are just
excellent
i'm away from home right now i don't
have my my pillow and that is one reason
i'm not sleeping great can't wait to get
back home hop on that my pillow you
should get one as well give them a call
800-651-1148
mypillar.com enter code daily where the
deals are not going to last forever call
right now okay so
the actual minute-by-minute narrative
we'll get to in a month but first you
have to you have to hear
jucy's account in his own words so first
of all
it does
raise the question as to who the casting
director was in hollywood who thought
that juicy sommelier should ever been
cast in anything because he's an actor
and one thing that you're supposed to be
able to do as an actor
is act i thought that was actually
implicit in the name actor but it turns
out that juicy is not only
first of all never let actors write
their own lines it's always a mistake
it's just whenever an actor is like i
think this line is bad i'm rewriting it
and when you let the actor write the
plot
it's a rare actor who can pull that off
you see was not that guy so he wrote a
really bad plot with really bad dialogue
and then he reenacted it in front of all
of us he went on good morning america
with robin robert
and uh and he was asked about his
message to the gay community
what do you say to a young gay man a
young gay person to learn to fight
and i don't just mean like learn to
fight
i mean
learn to fight
learn to be a fighter i am not
advocating violence
at all so let's be clear about that if
you're gonna die
fight until you do
because if you don't fight you have no
chance i have fought for love i'm an
advocate
i respect too much
the people
who i am now one of those people who
have been attacked in any way
you do such a disservice when you lie
about things like this oh
do you
do you jesus
ah
i have a message to you you gotta learn
to fight
like for example when you're trying to
punch yourself in the balls you really
should stop yourself from punching
yourself in the balls by punching
yourself in the balls
that's the way to fight
so to fight
fight for love
fight for love then people are like this
guy's credible he's so credible look at
the emotion it's written across his face
sorry
sorry okay then
but he had to run the gamut of emotions
in this good morning america abc news
interview with robin roberts the gamut
of emotion there was tears
there was laughter there was rage pure
visceral rage at the injustice of being
attacked by two nigerian guys you hired
to attack you while holding a subway
sandwich
jesse
tell us about the rage boiling within
you
i'm pissed off
what
is it that has you so
angry is it the
the attackers the attackers but it's
also
the attacks
oh it's like you know at first it was a
thing of like
listen if i tell the truth
then
that's it because it's the truth
then it became a thing of like
oh
how can you doubt that like how do you
how do you not believe that it's the
truth
and then it became a thing of like oh
it's not necessarily that you don't
believe
that this is the truth you don't even
want to see
the truth no as it turns out it was the
other thing where we didn't believe you
oh it's so good
okay
wait wait it gets better because then
you see writing his own lines here he
starts breaking into double negative
territory which is uh which is real
solid stuff okay uh i need to regain my
composure while we play this clip go
ahead
there is no doubt in your mind
what motivated this attack no it could
only go off of their words
i mean
who
says
empire
this maga country
mew you do that
ties a noose around your neck
and pours bleach on you
and this is just a friendly fight i will
never be
the man that this did not happen to
i am forever changed
he will never be the man this did not
happen to
never no never and never in the know
um i can't admit you know he what was he
he doesn't know what was going through
he knows exactly what was going through
his attacker's head as it turns out he
knows precisely down to the nitty-gritty
what was going on
in the attacker's head
and yeah that's that's real solid so he
trots this out and the entire media just
they they love it they love it now
pretty quickly the narrative starts to
fall apart
and get to their falling apart in a
second but first you have to understand
the overwhelming level of public support
that you see immediately received from
like the top people in america on the
left and it was universal
universal
nobody held back for more i mean this is
not a shock the entire left also still
claims that michael brown was murdered
by a police officer in cold blood
i mean the entire left still claims that
kyle rittenhouse is a racist murderer so
it's not a shock that they all jumped on
top of it but this one was so obviously
stupid that you would have thought that
maybe if they had like a sense like a
smidgen of self-preservation that they
might wait like this long to see if some
of the details didn't pan out because it
made no sense it made no internal sense
mega guys on the streets of chicago
i mean like what
and like attacking people while shouting
about
none of it made any sense at all but
they didn't wait and you know the reason
they didn't wait because when you're on
the left the great sin the thing you
will pay a price for is not commenting
you were the person who didn't comment
on this then you were bad then the mob
came after you because how dare you not
believe
how dare you not be the first to rush to
a microphone it demonstrates your lack
of fealty to the racial cause not to
jump on this and to and to emote about
it and to express your solidarity with
juicy and hashtag justice for jesus
and so everybody rushed because again
that's the incentive structure on the
left
there is no incentive structure on the
left to wait for the actual fact or to
put this even if it had happened
for a second which of course it didn't
to put that in the context that racial
that that wilfred riley puts it in
statistically speaking about race crime
stats
and no nobody would ever try to
contextualize this in terms of is this a
national representation of what life is
actually like in america for black men
nobody would attempt to do that because
that would demonstrate lack of field
teach the cause so your intensive
structure was you needed to rush to a
microphone you needed to rush to twitter
and you needed to sound off on how much
you believed juicy
and you had to beat your breast over it
you had to talk about how it was a deep
problem in america it was indicative of
just how evil and not only that it was
in the middle of the presidential race
it was indicative of trump it was all
about trump in fact the people wearing
maga hats that was probably trump
it was probably trump himself he
probably went to chicago and chopped
himself in half so there were two of him
and then each half of trump reunited and
bam attacked juicy sommelier
but left him gripping in horror and rage
that subway sandwich with two little
rank tuna fish
we'll get some more of this in just one
second because
honestly the show needs to go on for
like eight hours today let's just we're
gonna go from here to like the 2022
election just on this story because it's
that good we'll get to more on it in one
second first
if you're looking for ways to skip the
trip to the post office and dodge all
that hectic holiday shopping traffic why
not save time and money with stamps.com
stamps.com lets you compare rates print
labels access exclusive discounts on ups
and usps services all year long it just
makes sense especially if your business
sends more mail and packages during the
holidays here at dailywire we've used
stamps.com since 2017. no more wasting
our time whether you're selling online
or running an office or side hustle
stamps.com can save you so much time
money and stress during the holidays
access all the post office and ups
shipping services you need without
taking the trip and get discounts you
can't find anywhere else like up to 40
off usps rates and 76 off ups rates
going to the post office instead of
stamps.com it's kind of like taking the
stairs instead of the elevator if you're
going up a couple floors okay i get it
but if you're you know going up 10
stories
you got to take the elevator stamps.com
makes everything easier makes everything
cheaper save time and money this holiday
season with stamps.com sign up with
promo code shapiro for a special offer
that includes a four-week trial free
postage and digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com click the microphone at the
top of the page and enter promo code
shapiro okay so
the entire left world mobilized
immediately
you had joe biden who
rushed to twitter to tweet out using two
fingers because that's how he do it he
tweeted out what happened today to
jesse's melies must never be tolerated
in this country
we must stand up and demand that we no
longer give this hate safe harbor that
homophobia and racism have no place on
our streets or in our hearts we are with
you as you see
and um
i have good news
homophobia and racism had no place on
our streets because the attacker of
juicy similier
is going to prison meanwhile kamala
harris when she wasn't trying to bail
out rioters in the middle of the blm
riots
that would be just a little while later
this is 20 this is january 2019.
she tweets out
jesse smollett is one of the kindest
most gentle human beings i know
well not to jesse as it turns out he was
he was not so kind or gentle to jesse
i'm praying for his quick recovery this
was an attempted modern day lynching by
the way this tweet is still up no one
should have to fear for their life
because of their sexuality or color of
their skin we must confront this hate it
was an attempt in modern day lynching
by jesse smilet against jesse smallett
such lynchings have to end
nancy pelosi who now has deleted this
tweet she tweeted the racist homophobic
attack and justice
is an affront to our humanity
no one should be attacked for who they
are or whom they love i pray that jesse
has a speedy recovery and that justice
is served may we all commit to ending
this hate
once and for all
also moving so moving
maxine waters
who uh
has yet to find a race riot that she
doesn't love she tweeted out jesse is my
friend a very talented and beautiful
human being so she's wrong on both of
those things he is not talented and he
is not a beautiful human being it is so
hurtful that homophobic haters would
dare hurt someone so loving
and giving
of checks to nigerian immigrants
to
beat him up
i'm dedicated to finding the culprits
and bringing them to justice
i have some good news maxine
her search was not in vain she was
dedicated like o.j simpson to finding
the real killer she was dedicated to
finding the culprits and bringing them
to justice jesse did not deserve to be
harmed by anyone again i have good news
he was not harmed by anyone so that's
good
dedicated to finding the culprits and
bringing them to justice by the way has
maxine waters ever said this about you
know an innocent black person killed by
a black person which is the vast
majority of black people who are killed
in this country because it turns out
that intra-racial crime is significantly
more common than inter-racial
crime okay and then um there was bernie
bernie sounded off we could do this all
day gang i got all the receipts today
bernie sanders tweeted the racist and
homophobic attack on justice bullet is a
horrific instance of the surging
hostility to minorities around the
country we must come together to cook
all forms of bigotry and violence here's
the thing
the supply of racism and bigotry in
america is so low and the demand on the
left is so high that even a completely
false ridiculous on its face story like
this had to be treated as gospel truth
by the entire left top to bottom side to
side i mean everyone everyone any
expression of that was tantamount to a
form of heresy
he tweeted out while the struggle for
basic hate crime legislation continues
here in indiana this horrible attack
calls all americans to stand against
hatred and violence in all of its forms
i'd finish this tweet but i'm on
paternity leave
and then of course there was kirsten
gillibrand
the the the one-time presidential
candidate i say one time because it
literally was one time it was like for a
minute she tweeted this is a sickening
an outrageous attack and horribly it's
the latest of too many hate crimes
against lgbtq plus iaa backslash colon
little squiggly thing tilde over the end
that said that turns nina into ninaya in
spanish
people and people of color we are all
responsible for condemning this behavior
and every person who enables or
normalizes it praying for juicy and his
family
we are all responsible for condemning
this behavior and every person who
enables or normalizes it
who has enabled or normalized this
behavior kirsten jollibrand who would
enable or normalize race hoax behavior
who
who would do such a thing kirsten
gillibrand
who
and then the irrepressible
the fresh so fresh so face
freshly mcface head alexandra
ocasio-cortez representative from twitch
she tweeted
there is no there's an and there's a
headline from entertainment today that
said jesse smellette has been
hospitalized in chicago after a possible
homophobic and racially charged attack
and she said there is no such thing as
racially charged this attack was not
possibly homophobic it was racist and
homophobic
if you don't like what is happening to
our country work to change it it's no
one's job to water down or sugarcoat the
rise of hate crimes
also here i am sugar coating
anti-semitism
uh rashida talib sound it off as well
uh
when one of the most famous black and
gay men in america is not safe the
message is clearer than it ever has been
she was quoting an article from gq
the dangerous lies spewing from the
right wing is killing and hurting our
people thinking of you jesse smilet and
my
lgbtq plus i a plus l you y dollar sign
neighbors
the dangerous lies is spewing from the
right wing is killing and hurting i feel
like that was not the lie here but you
needed to tell it didn't you didn't you
okay and then of course you had the
activist groups he had color of change
which issued a statement at the time
saying that the attack was a reminder of
the real violence black lgbtq people
face every day well um it's not a
reminder so much of the real violence
that they they face every day as a
reminder of the fake violence that they
hate that they face every day because it
turns out that he was lying and pretty
obviously lying
glad put out a statement at the time
saying jesse's experience is sadly not
unique in today's america by the way
that's true race hoaxes happen on a
fairly regular basis in the united
states right now because the incentive
structure is very much in favor of race
hoaxes
this has been happening like a lot in
the like shockingly a lot in the united
states this doesn't mean that there
aren't hate crimes doesn't mean there
isn't interracial crime white on black
although interracial crime black on
white is significantly more common
but the the race craw the race hoax
issue is a real issue
and pretending that it's not
is ignoring the state of play in the
country okay and then of course you had
the entire celebrity class so ariana
grande
she tweeted out what happened to jesse
makes me really effing sick to my
stomach i can't believe bleep like this
is really still happening every day i
can't i can't believe it either because
number one it's not really happening
every day and also because it's not so
that what kind of world question mark
sending all of the healing energy slash
love i possibly can and hoping for
change what can we do tell me and i'm
there well you could you know not help
propagate a lie shonda rhymes she
tweeted we all have a responsibility to
rise up against the ignorance and hate
out there if you know who did this to
jesse smallette report them to police
i'm on it
i know who did this to jesse's malette
kerry washington tweeted dear god
she stares up to the heavens tears
pouring down her face why oh god why
prayers and justice
for jesus
uh justice came for jesse smilier but
not in the be careful what you wish for
zendaya
tweeted out this is terrifying and
heartbreaking please pay attention to
what's happening here well the problem
is we kind of did that was the problem
in this story because juicy probably
thought okay well i'll tell my tale
maybe i won't even go to the cops
and then it'll all be like i was a hero
and then everybody was like well you
know when you do that we pay really
close attention and he's like well
then you get the homer simpson gif of
him just like backing into a bush
reverend al sharpton who uh
is always a plausible source when it
comes to the veracity of interracial
hate crimes it's not like al sharpton
who still has a show on msnbc it's not
like he actively propagated the lie that
a manhattan d.a
raped
an underage black girl and then scrawled
racial slurs on her in feces back in the
1980s
that'd be the tawanna bradley hoax
al sharpton would never be complicit in
something like that so i take his
judgment
really like he has solid judgment on
what is true and what is false when it
comes to race hoaxes
he tweeted out at the time the reported
hate attack on my friend and brother
after jesse smilet is despicable and
outrageous the guilty must face the
maximum
i come bearing glad tidings reverend al
the guilty must face the maximum
viola davis tweeted omg
double exclamation point
this is why the lgbtq plus i a op
open bracket close bracket backslash
double quotation mark
carrot
little weird thing above the option
button
this is why that community continues to
fight to be seen and protected against
hate we all have to take this racist and
homophobic attack to violence very
personally my arms are around you
justice smith you are loved well the
good news for jesse smith is that
justice mullets arms were also around
justice millett when jesse smallett was
attacking jesse smilet in the middle of
a hate crime against jesse smith
ellen's generous tweeted about it and
i'm sending him and his family so much
love today so much love shares was
pretty great sure tweeted out
the best thing about shara's twitter
account is that she's so clearly drunk
when she writes these tweets
like the cap slot goes on and she's you
have to imagine when chair tweets these
things that the caps lock button goes on
and she knows about halfway through the
tweet that it's on she's like ah
emoji
so here's what she tweeted jesse
smallett empire actor reportedly
attacked impossible hate crime npr
villainy
racism
oh
phobia promoted by most infamous clown
clown emoji in world emoji is the poison
that kills american flag
period
no space white only is not right period
american flag is
of color praying hands
gop goes down with ship
digit
small digit
ah cher it's that sort of insight
that um that makes you such a wondrous
addition to america's political
discourse
so you had the entire political
infrastructure that came to uh jucie's
defense you had the entire entertainment
infrastructure that came to jucy's
defense he had prominent members of the
media who were helping out as it turns
out don lemon was texting with juicy and
telling jucy that the police didn't
believe him which seems to be kind of a
violation of journalistic ethics you had
places like gq writing articles titled
the racist homophobic attack on juicy
smoothie is america's end game
end game
and by the way they didn't present it as
an opinion piece originally it presented
it as just a journalistic piece then
later they were like oh yeah it's an
opinion piece the editor's notes on this
are pretty spectacular the editors note
222 in the original version of this
piece
gq made two errors in editorial judgment
we failed to clearly present the post as
an opinion piece
and we regret applying unfounded
political motivations to then breaking
news with the original headline
we have altered the headline
juicy update justice malay was arrested
update the story is fast moving we're
keeping an eye on the news as it
develops whoopsie doodle but again the
entire piece is predicated on the idea
that juicy sommelier is representative
of black men in america and gay men in
america and none of that is true
none of that is true but that was the
narrative that's why they did this if it
were not a narrative story wouldn't
matter
and by the way it is important to
remember that juicy was part and parcel
of the left-wing infrastructure okay he
was a very political actor he was always
political and he kind of fell out of
prominence because the obamas were no
longer in office and so him hanging out
with michelle obama just wasn't the same
but i mean this is a guy who literally
went dancing with michelle obama right
this is a person who was very political
i mean here's some video of him dancing
with michelle obama back in 2018. uh how
the how the mighty have fallen here he
was dancing with michelle obama one year
before he faked a hate crime against
himself
[Applause]
[Music]
by the way it didn't it wasn't just that
he danced with michelle obama as it
turns out
at the time
tina chen's longtime friend was not
surprised that the former obama
administration aide helped connect jesse
smelly's family with a top illinois
prosecutor weeks before a grand jury
indicted smolette on the theory he
falsely reported being the victim of a
hate crime relatives of the actor had
expressed to tina chen concerns about
the investigation by chicago pd
getting the right person to take those
sorts of concerns seriously has been a
hallmark of tina chen's career
highlighted by a stint as then first
lady michelle obama's chief of staff
so she reached out michelle obama's
chief of staff
to prosecutors to try and work on behalf
of jessie smilet
chen said her contact with kim fox on
behalf of smart's family was not
intended to influence the case outcome
oh sure it wasn't
shortly after smellette reported he was
attacked as a family friend i contacted
cook county state's attorney kim foxx
who i also know from prior work together
she said
my sole activity was to put the chief
prosecutor in the case in touch with an
alleged victim's family who had concerns
about how the investigation was being
characterized in public
so um
that was how tied in jesse smallett was
what to do to the infrastructure here
now we have to go back to what exactly
happened what the timeline was because
honestly it's it's just it's a wonderful
timeline and then we'll get to the
defense that jucy tried to provide for
his behavior
first it's the christmas and holiday
season it's time for gift givings and
parties for only a few more weeks
genusl's most popular package is sixty
percent off at genusell.com give the
gift to people of looking years younger
treat yourself in a loved one to the
absolute best skin care on planet earth
you can see the fine lines forehead
wrinkles pesky bags and puffiness
annoying dark spots yes even a sagging
draw line disappear before your eyes
with genus cells classic collection with
its immediate effects you can see
results in less than 12 hours guaranteed
or your money backs you really have
nothing to lose
my wife has been using jenny's hell for
a very long time
my mom uses gen you sell as well you're
guaranteed to get your genus in time for
the holidays since every product is made
here in the good old usa order now get
your complimentary spa package
absolutely free at checkout
shamanism world-class microdermabrasion
treatment cleanser and toner makes the
perfect stocking stuffer visit
genusell.com right now that's
g-e-n-u-c-e-l.com right now enter my
special promo ben35 for an additional 35
bucks off every order today is instantly
upgraded to free express shipping head
on over to genusell.com that is
genusell.com go check it out right now
alrighty before we go further down
memory lane and actually examine what
happened that night as the police began
to investigate because we have a full
timeline it's that glorious time of the
week when i give a shout out to a daily
where i remember today it's justin
anderson on instagram who sums up what
many voters on the left are currently
feeling in the pic justin is sporting an
american flag hat clutching the world's
greatest beverage vessel while out for
an afternoon drive the caption reads
cruising the internet relishing the
left's despair as they cry sweet tears
of embarrassment and humiliation after
slowly realizing that the sweet old man
they thought they voted for turned out
to be the worst president in american
history nice work libs thanks for the
tumblr real daily wire hashtag leftist
tears tumbler
well put well put thanks for the pick
thanks for being a daily wire member
also the bite administration's
unconstitutional vax mandate not doing
well in court not only has the osha
mandate received a nationwide stay but
the u.s senate voted 52-48 against joe
biden's federal mandate the issue now
goes to the house who are probably going
to just uphold the vaccine mandate and
then biden can veto it anyway which is
why we can't leave a contentious issue
up to the biden administration instead
we've taken matters into our own hands
putting our own business at risk we were
the first in the nation to file suit
against joe biden's authoritarian
mandate there will be many many more the
onus is on us the people to try to fight
back when they try to force our
compliance what we put in our bodies
really should not be up to the
government neither is how we spend our
holidays which biden's winter covered
plan he's hinting now that he kind of
wants to shut down christmas again right
anthony fauci said that maybe we should
actually put vax mandates on people
before they fly domestically which means
that if you want to actually go see your
members of your family you either have
to take a car or you have to vax if
anthony fauci gets his way now they kind
of floated that as a tribal and we'll
see if it happens but this is clearly
the direction they are thinking our
collective voices have never been more
important in the fight for freedom
now's your chance to add your voice to
the fight if you haven't signed our
petition against biden's vax mandate
please head on over to dailywire.com do
not comply and add your name we should
send an overwhelming message to this
administration that we are not going to
comply we're trying to get to a million
signatures we're at about 800 000
signatures so far we need your help to
cross that finish line so please sign
the petition at dailywire.com do not
comply share that position with all your
friends and family let's send a really
loud and clear message
also
matt walsh is now a best-selling
children's book author
actually now that he's a best-selling
children's book author you're starting
to see the twitter activist upset
because his book is at the top of the
lgbtq plus i double a plus minus
exclamation point backslash emoji
clown face bestsellers list this is the
work of bigots you should not stand for
this attempt to cancel
an advocate for trans walrus
like matt walsh if you'd like to help
support him in his mission to help the
lgbtq plus w
community head on over to amazon to
reserve your copy right now it's sold
out within the first of 24 hours of its
release you can get your hands on the
next batch that is shipping out soon
johnny the walrus it's a magnificent
tale of heroism and joy it's about a
young boy who pretends he's walrus and
uh and then his mommy goes to yoga class
and is told that no actually johnny is a
walrus and you have to uphold his trans
walrus identity
the book is hysterically funny you
should pick up a copy go get it right
now
head on over to amazon reserve your copy
of that masterpiece johnny the walrus
today you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so now let's go through the
actual timeline of what happened with
jesse because it's really really funny
okay so 12 30 a.m this is according to
the chicago tribune sommelier arrives at
o'hare international airport on a flight
from new york after a four-hour delay at
12 49 a.m smelly called abimbola
usandero told him the attack would take
place at 2 am at the corner of new and
north water streets a predetermined
location
minutes later
that guy's brother alabinju
ordered an uber ride chair which picks
the brothers up at their lakeview
apartment and drops them in the 1400
block of north well street they hailed
the cab which took them to within three
blocks of the meeting site from 1 22 a.m
until 203 am surveillance videos show
the usondero brothers on foot in an area
bordered on the north by illinois street
south by the chicago river west to
columbus drive east to lake shore 1 30
a.m smileth arrived at his apartment 145
he left his apartment building to walk
to a nearby subreddit restaurant again
this is where the suspicious activity
begins 2 a.m the osandero brothers
arrived at the intersection of new and
north water streets but smellette was
not there they walked a quarter block
north and waited near a bench
at 204 smolette arrives and the attack
was staged just outside the view of a
nearby surveillance camera he would
later claim that two white men
approached him shouted slurs at him
struck him in the face and poured an
unknown substance on him before one of
them wrapped a rope around his neck
while the 45 second incident occurs an
employee of nearby nbc news chicago
observed it and later tells police she
heard nothing smelled also said he was
on the phone with his manager at the
time of the attack and then after the
attack there was video evidence showing
the brothers running away
and then they got into a taxi and then
they got out of the taxi at their
apartment and walked north
at 2 27 am smallett's business manager
frank gatson called the cops from the
actor's apartment surveillance camera
footage shows the actor still had the
rope around his neck when he returned to
the building which is definitely what
you do when someone tries to gear at you
you just keep that hanging around i mean
why not
2 42 officers arrived at smallett's
apartment building to interview him they
observed cuts and scrapes on his face
and noticed a small rope around his neck
at smilet's request the officers turned
off the body cameras
of course according to chicago police
spokesperson anthony googliem googly
elmy told the attackers that he told
them the attacker was yelled he was in
maga country and then he went to the
hospital
and then
18 hours after the attack he placed a
five second call to one of the brothers
and uh and then a little bit later uh
they placed a call back to juicy
smoothie
okay so that was that was the actual
timeline of of what happened
i i think that it is i think it is
necessary for us to just remind
ourselves of how absurd this whole thing
was within days of all this coming out
jucy's attorneys
claimed that the reason that juicy
was attacked by two black men not two
white men and then gc reported that it
was two white men that the reason that
this happened is because maybe
maybe
the two nigerian brothers were wearing
white face
mm-hmm
what are the chances that that's the
case that he saw
somebody with light skin well you know i
mean i think there's
obviously you can disguise that you
could put makeup on there is actually
interestingly enough a video you know i
think police did minimal investigation
in this case it was it took me all of
five minutes to google you know i was
looking up the brothers and one of the
first videos that showed up actually was
one of the brothers in white face doing
a joker monologue with white makeup on
and so it's not it's not implausible uh
no actually it's super duper pooper
scooper implausible
i love that we're so far down the
america is racist rabbit hole in order
to prove america is racist a black gay
man had to fake an attack on himself by
hiring two brothers from nigeria
and then have his lawyer claim on
national television that it was two
black people who dressed up as white
people to attack him
yeah man
i i feel like for all the people who say
systemic racism is the is the nature of
all of the yeah i i have some questions
there's a great article
by kyle smith over at national review
going through some of the details of the
magic of the juicy smoothie trial it's
titled the juicy smoothie funniest trial
ever
yep
he says the prosecution made a case that
was zero tight locked down seamless as
an egg so what did team smellette do
they whined there should be a mistrial
because the judge had snarled and lunged
at them
the judge missed the opportunity to say
i only scenario when my bushwa detector
goes off like a geiger count or a
chernobyl i can't very well lunge when
i'm sitting at this desk the defense
lawyers asked for a directed not guilty
finding which was so sweet it was like
learning an eighth grader had written to
emily ratajkowski with an earnest
proposal of marriage
publicist called upon to testify by his
side noted that a celebrity whose
earning potential depended on his face
would not want to undergo any process
that might significantly damage said
face
just so cried america
because he didn't damage his face
as for someone's pals testifying against
him they produced a 3 500 check juicy
had written them as an advanced payment
because the ringmaster of this flea
circus was too dumb to understand that
cash is the preferred payment method
when doing stuff you don't want others
to find out about
what lawyers tried to explain this was
for nutritional tips
the supposed nutritional advisory
siblings said no one had ever paid them
more than a hundred dollars for such
advice before
also they uh they were texting each
other beforehand and they were using
uber
and um yeah it was it was just a genius
move all the way through
framing the attack is an episode of
homophobia opens up more questions than
that smallet can't answer if the
brothers were looking to attack a random
gay person and had an irrepressible 2 am
urged to do so why didn't they go to the
gay neighborhood where one of them
worked
why are they hanging around over here
and the answer is because it was all it
was all bull so here's the thing by
april of 2019 we all knew this was bull
and the media kept trying to proclaim
that maybe it was true maybe it was true
but black comedians were having none of
it
tracy morgan april 2019
mocking all this like i have to tell you
the the woke white people are just the
worst okay i want to contrast something
so here is
here is ellen page okay sorry now this
is elliott page okay this is when ella
elliott was ellen
elliott is still
a woman but now has had some surgeries
and is a trans man this is when elliott
was ellen and
trying to present as a woman
america were in great shape here was uh
here was
elliott nay ellen page i'm going to say
this is ellen page because at the time
this was ellen page okay so there's
ellen page who was with stephen colbert
both of them agreeing that to even doubt
juicy smelly's story demonstrated that
you didn't take seriously the problem of
gay black americans or some such
we have a media that's saying it's a
debate whether or not which has happened
to jesse smallett is a hate crime it's
absurd
this isn't a debate
it's a little of a debate
a little and stephen colbert he says i
agree
i agree
because that's what matters it's the
agreement among the elites so here's the
thing why would you ever trust these
people again
why would you ever ever ever trust these
people again and you shouldn't you
shouldn't because they're so full of it
they're full of it every like at the
very least you should wait to draw a
conclusion from any headline they report
24-hour rule okay wait 24 hours and see
if any story they report bears
elementary scrutiny
because they will report anything that
backs their narrative even a story as
ridiculous as juicy smilies and honestly
i'm just happy to be living in a country
where people who conspire to commit an
attack on a gay black man by other gay
black men hired by the original gay
black man where those people go to
prison where they can share a cell with
the gay black man because they're the
same
human
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content first
you can't forget to end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show
drew's shows every friday as always he
has an exciting and romantic evening
plan for you so head on over to
dailywire.com at 7 p.m eastern 6 pm
central and tune in i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin